ja und bei uns jetzt der
bundesaußenminister heiko maas wie du
gesagt hast herzlich willkommen heiko
maas luftbrücke sie sprechen von einer
luftbrücke und der lufthansa chef
carsten spohr tut das auch luftbrücke um
deutsche urlauber zurückzuholen
luftbrücke aber auch um den warenverkehr
zu sichern in deutschland ist dieser
begriff tatsächlich angemessen ist das
eine vergleichbare situation wie 1949
als west berlin über eine solche
luftbrücke versorgt wurde
nein das ist nicht vergleichbar es gibt
auch keine historischen vergleiche die
jetzt gezogen werden sollen aber
faktisch ist es tatsächlich so dass wir
im moment dabei sind wenn alles
funktioniert wir brauchen
überfluggenehmigung landeerlaubnis die
innerhalb kürzester zeit organisiert
werden müssen
aber wenn das alles heute im laufe des
tages so läuft wie wir uns das
vorstellen werden wir bis zu 30 40
flieger in die luft bekommen die an
unterschiedliche destinationen fliegen
die deutschen urlauber zurückbringen und
die wenn sie in deutschland abgeliefert
worden sind sofort wieder zurück fliegen
also faktisch hat dass tatsächlich etwas
mit einer luftbrücke zu tun ohne dass
das jetzt ein historische vergleiche
angriffen also eine gewaltige
rückholaktion haben sie verständnis
dafür in diesen zeiten überhaupt noch in
den urlaub zum beispiel nach asien
geflogen zu sein
na ja man wird sicherlich die gründe die
jeder hat noch mal im einzelnen
analysieren müssen aber so richtig
verständnis nicht weiß wo es jeder für
sich entscheiden
möglicherweise gibt es auch persönliche
gründe die dabei eine ausnahme machen
können aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kann
man das niemandem raten deshalb haben
wir auch formal eine reisewarnung
ausgesprochen
wir stellen fest dass der flugverkehr
insgesamt international am
zusammenbrechen ist das ist immer
schwerer ist landeerlaubnis zu bekommen
und deshalb können wir auch nicht sagen
ob wir in zwei wochen noch in der lage
sind eine solche aktion wie heute
gestartet zu machen und deshalb kann
eigentlich niemand der verantwortlich
handelt jetzt noch etwas trotzdem macht
müsste seinen flug dann selber zahlen
sei eine rückholung mehr grundsätzlich
müssen die die zurückkommen
natürlich auch in irgendeiner weise sich
beteiligen das haben wir jetzt aber
alles mal zurückgestellt und gesagt wir
wollen das jetzt vor allen dingen
schnell unbürokratisch auf den weg
bringen deshalb wird die bundesregierung
die maschinen etwa bei der lufthansa bei
der condor und auch bei der tour wurde
der größte block bei der lufthansa auf
eigene kosten scheitern und das wie das
nachher abgebildet wird das stellen wir
mal zurück das ist jetzt nicht unser
problem und deshalb haben wir 50
millionen euro zur verfügung wir reden
wirklich über eine große anzahl von
touristen die noch im ausland sind
teilweise kommen die ganz regulär zurück
weil der flugverkehr noch funktioniert
aber alleine in ägypten sind es 35
deutsche touristen die jetzt zurück
wollen die teilweise mit ihren
fluggesellschaften und reiseanbietern
zurückkommen aber eben nicht mehr alle
ab dem 19
wird dort der flugverkehr dichtgemacht
in luxor in ägypten und deshalb
organisieren wir jetzt in nach marokko
in die philippinen dominikanische
republik ist das magazin gestand alle
müssen wir den anstand eigentlich
einhalten in den flieger an der zeit
meter weil dann sind das ja
weitestgehend lehre fliegen
na ja also es kann durchaus sein dass
die flieger nicht immer voll sein werden
aber wir gehen davon aus dass jetzt erst
mal die leute zurück gebracht werden
müssen und die flieger auch gut besetzt
sind so und deshalb wird natürlich jeder
der in deutschland ankommt noch einmal
überprüfen müssen ob er symptome hat
sich untersuchen lassen aber jetzt geht
es erstmal darum die leute die irgendwo
sitzen die hotels haben dich gemacht die
nicht mehr wissen wohin mit ihnen dass
wir die so schnell wie möglich zurück
bringen das wird nicht immer in 24
stunden aktionen möglich sein also ich
bitte einfach auch um verständnis aber
wir organisieren jetzt sich eine masse
von fliegern die zum glück auch zur
verfügung steht weil die lufthansa
praktisch nicht mehr fliegt ins ausland
um die leute von einem auf den anderen
tag auch zurückbringen zu können
wir haben das personal im auswärtigen
amt aufgestockt damit die leute sich
gleich ans krisenreaktionszentrum wenden
können also es ist wirklich eine
unglaublich große aktionen die aber auch
notwendig ist weil die situation in
einzelnen ländern
für touristen wirklich mehr als
unangenehm geworden ist was passiert mit
den menschen die jetzt zurückgeholt
werden wenn sie sozusagen aus
krisenländern kommen wo der virus
besonders verbreitet ist müssen die hier
in deutschland in quarantäne
und ja wir haben ja bestimmte regelungen
für länder die als risikogebiet erklärt
worden sind das heißt dort gibt es
verschärfte bedingungen dort muss
untersucht werden
und wenn symptome festgestellt werden
oder fieber bei der einreise
festgestellt wird also da wird und wie
gemessen dabei auch tatsächlich nicht
wie bei anderen flieger ein bisschen
leiden
wir stellen ja fest dass bei dem was in
der vergangenheit geschehen ist die
dinge jetzt optimiert werden es wird der
bestimmte risikogebiete ausdehnen wird
ist keine flüge mehr geben ich hoffe
dass die europäische union heute eine
regelung schafft das aus allen nicht
schengen staaten die einreise erschwert
wird bis unterbunden wird aber die
deutschen staatsbürger haben natürlich
den anspruch zurück nach deutschland zu
kommen und wenn sie aus gebieten kommen
die problematisch sind müssen sie
untersucht werden und dann auch die
notwendigen konsequenzen daraus gezogen
wie gehen sie eigentlich persönlich
damit um ihr job besteht ein nicht darin
in andere länder zu fliegen das machen
sie fast das ganze jahr über was machen
sie denn jetzt
das ist tatsächlich so und mein
terminplan hat sich auch fundamental
verändert bis ostern gibt es überhaupt
keine reise mehr ist heute eigentlich in
die usa nach südafrika nach
lateinamerika wir haben das jetzt alles
erst einmal zurückgestellt
heute morgen hatten wir eine
video-konferenz mit den baltischen
staaten es gibt so ein format die
baltischen staaten plus deutschland
eigentlich wollten wir uns auch treffen
wir haben das jetzt per video format
gemacht wir werden nächsten montag ein
treffen der außenminister der
europäischen union haben das unbedingt
stattfinden muss weil wir müssen ja
diese fragen auch viel stärker
europäisch koordinieren das findet jetzt
in einer große video konferenz statt
das ist eine umstellung sicherlich auch
nicht ganz so wie ein persönliches
treffen aber es geht nicht anders wir
müssen viele dinge viel mehr
international organisieren und deshalb
gibt es jetzt keine persönlichen treffen
mehr als die videokonferenzen
telefonschaltkonferenz ist alles ein
bisschen anders aber geht alles wenn wir
über diplomatie sprechen viele menschen
die jetzt über den virus diskutieren
sind wütend auf schienen
sind wütend darüber dass möglicherweise
lange nicht die ganze wahrheit über
corona erzählt wurde wie geht es ihnen
sind sie wütend darüber dass er
möglicherweise am anfang etwas vertuscht
wurde
wer also wir alle haben ja gesehen dass
die chinesischen behörden eine zeitlang
gebraucht haben um auch die dimension
dieser zeit gebraucht oder war das in
einer eine propaganda sozusagen der
chinesischen will ich will das nicht
ausschließen dass auch zunächst einmal
versucht worden ist das zu unterdrücken
das ist aber irgendwann erkannt worden
dass das nicht geht ist mit drastischen
maßnahmen reagiert worden die in offenen
gesellschaften wie bei uns in europa so
eigentlich gar nicht vorstellbar waren
jetzt treffen wir selber drastische
maßnahmen die wir hier in deutschland
beschlossen haben die auch in anderen
ländern beschlossen worden sind aber das
zeigt dass das unterdrücken das
verheimlichen im iran ist es ja noch
viel schlimmer die dunkelziffer im iran
kennt überhaupt keiner sagen sie dann
immer noch flüge aus dem iran hier land
nährt auch das wird sicher verändern wir
haben immer darum hat das so lange wir
haben auf einer vergangenheit flüge
gebraucht auch um deutsche aus dem iran
zurück zu holen also ganz so einfach ist
es nicht aber mit der regelung die
hoffentlich heute bei den staatsschatz
auf europäischer ebene getroffen wird
wird auch in zukunft nicht schengen
staaten ist nicht mehr möglich sein
einfach flüge nach deutschland durch zu
sagen eine letzte frage zu china im
februar haben sie noch dafür gesorgt
dass schutzmasken richtung china
geliefert wurden dafür gibt es jetzt
kritik fehlen uns am ende diese massen
diese schutzkleidung in deutschland nein
also wir haben ja einige maßnahmen
erlassen auch exportverbot für güter die
wir hier brauchen bei dem was wir hier
brauchen sind wir nach wie vor gut
ausgestattet natürlich müssen wir
zunächst einmal die eigenen bedarf
decken das was wir geholfen haben in
china hat im übrigen auch dabei geholfen
das wird bei dieser virus sich nicht
noch schneller verbreitet es wäre nicht
auszudenken gewesen wenn das in china
nicht in den griff gekriegt wird was das
auch für eine stelle leute ist ja nicht
in den griff bekommen also niemand hat
es im ergebnis so weit im griff dass er
sagen könnte das problem ist gelöst
es gibt länder in denen sind die
verläufe nicht so dramatisch wie in
anderen
wir werden in china sehen ob das was
dort verkündet wird nämlich dass die
infektion zurückgehen das
wirtschaftliche prozesse wieder anlaufen
ob das wirklich nachhaltig ist aber
letztlich sind wir mit denen materialien
die wir haben und mit den
schutzausrüstung gut ausgestattet und
ehrlich gesagt die meisten anderen
staaten auf der welt wir haben vor sie
wären so ausgestattet wie wir in
deutschland ja und das ist noch mal
konkret zu machen die erfahrungen im
alltag ist im moment etwas anderes sind
keine apotheke gibt es mehr
desinfektionsmittel oder in kaum einer
wir kriegen das aktuell nicht mehr wenn
wir in die apotheke gehen schutzkleidung
auch nicht und wenige wochen zuvor haben
sie all das nach china fliegen lassen
deswegen noch mal die frage ist das
nächste jeder weiß dass jeder punkt
zuvor haben wir das alles nach china
fliegen lassen so ist das nicht also es
gab eine flugzeug ladung die dahin
geschickt worden ist und im rahmen der
humanitären hilfe ist das auch nach wie
vor richtig das hat nicht dazu geführt
dass es in deutschland
versorgungsengpässe gibt die tatsache
dass im moment die leute wenn sie
einkaufen in der apotheke oder im
supermarkt
ich würde mal sagen deutlich mehr kaufen
als sie gleich unbedingt bräuchten
er hat natürlich auch etwas damit zu tun
dass es schwerer wird die regale
aufzuführen aber bei allem was wir hören
sowohl aus der lebensmittelindustrie als
auch aus der pharmazeutischen industrie
gibt es verzögerungen bei den
nachlieferungen aber auch aufgrund der
tatsache dass die leute natürlich total
meint die maßnahmen die wir beschlossen
haben so was gab es in deutschland noch
nicht oder ich muss jetzt muss man das
erstmal verdauen der entstehen auch
ängste da geht man ins geschäft oder in
die apotheke oder karten braucht kauft
das was man braucht ein gleich mal in
dreifacher ausführung
ich glaube das muss man einfach so
akzeptieren aber die lieferketten
funktionieren sie funktionieren auch ins
ins ausland und vor allen dingen vom
ausland aus ist ist es gut dass die
lufthansa uns nicht nur unterstützt
deutsche staatsbürger zurück zu nehmen
auch die lieferketten über luft weiter
zu organisieren insofern mag ist
insofern mag es etwas länger dauern bis
die regale wieder aufgeführt werden aber
sie werden weiter gefüllt das robert
koch institut spricht mittlerweile von
einer hohen gefahr hat also diese stufe
noch mal aufgesetzt auf hoch wann kommt
die ausgangssperre für deutschland also
wir haben jetzt eine ein bündel von
maßnahmen beschlossen gerade erst
gestern das wirklich massiv ist
ist ein umfassender shutdown des
öffentlichen lebens öffentliche
einrichtungen schulen aber auch
geschäfte so und wir hoffen und wir
setzen darauf und das werden wir in den
nächsten tagen sehen dass diese
maßnahmen auch greifen und die
infektionsrate abgeflacht wird es gibt
ja niemanden der behauptet es wird jetzt
keine neuen infektionen mehr geben
sondern wir wollen die kurve nicht mehr
so verlaufen lassen wie das in der
vergangenheit sich angedeutet hat weil
ansonsten unsere gesundheit dieser
serien erwartungen die kurve wird sich
abflachen dass wir haben alle wir tun
alles dafür dass sie nicht so
exponentiell verläuft wie das befürchtet
würde wenn wir nichts tun wie weit das
dann wird diese maßnahmen das werden wir
es in den nächsten tagen sehen und wir
werden weiterhin im krisenstab auch dem
krisenstab der bundesregierung diese
entwicklung verfolgen uns mit den
experten im robert-koch-institut
absprechen und überlegen welche
maßnahmen in zukunft noch ergriffen
werden müssen nach all dem was wir mit
den experten vom robert koch institut
besprochen haben sind die maßnahmen die
jetzt ergriffen worden sind
die die notwendig gewesen sind alles was
danach kommt wird man glauben wir alles
sehen wenn man sieht wie die infektions
kurve weiter verläuft aber dennoch wenn
wir in die anderen länder schauen in
unsere nachbarländer gestern gab es ein
dramatisches statement des französischen
präsidenten makro mikro hat gesagt wir
sind im krieg wenn wir darüber sprechen
sind wir auch in deutschland im krieg
der minister naja ich bin mit
begrifflichkeiten wie krieg hervor weil
sie wissen über kriege die zurzeit auf
der welt geführt werden und was da los
ist
ja das ist ein kampf und das ist ein
kampf wie wir ihn wahrscheinlich so in
deutschland noch nicht erlebt haben
gegen das virus
und es geht auch darum menschenleben zu
sichern denn wenn wir immer mehr
infektionen haben und immer mehr
menschen die auch erkrankt werden gott
sei dank erkranken ja nicht alle
menschen sondern nur ein geringer teil
aber diejenigen die risikopatienten sind
weise vorbelastet sind beweise besonders
alt sind
die müssen dann ärztlich versorgt werden
die müssen beatmet werden dafür gibt es
nur eine bestimmte kapazität
und deshalb müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
das gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet
wird
denn ansonsten hätten wir italienische
verhältnisse das überprüfen muss wer
kaum noch an ein beatmungsgerät oder
nicht das ist das was wir jetzt
versuchen das ist der grund weshalb das
robert koch institut die krankenhäuser
aufgefordert hat die anzahl der zur
verfügung stehenden betten jetzt erst
einmal zu verdoppeln um für alles
gerüstet zu sein und deshalb wird es
jetzt darum gehen in den kommenden tagen
zu überprüfen greifen die maßnahmen die
wir ergriffen haben die drastisch sind
und vor allen dingen in welchem umfang
greifen sie und dann müssen wir darüber
entscheiden wie wir mit der situation
die wir dann haben weiter umgehen
fürchten sie dass andere krisenherde
auch kriege in der welt wie
beispielsweise in syrien aus dem auge
geraten weiter noch aus dem auge geraten
als ohnehin schon durch die korona krise
und dann erst hat einfach ja quasi
unbemerkt weiter bomben ja das hoffe ich
nicht und das ist ja gerade das was wir
versuchen zu vermeiden indem wir die
außenpolitik jetzt nicht auch ein
shutdown sozusagen sondern dass wir uns
weiter treffen wir haben heute morgen zb
mit einigen kollegen aus europa auch
über die entwicklung in syrien
gesprochen was das bedeutet was mit dem
waffenstillstand ist heute wird
möglicherweise es noch einmal ein
gespräch geben der kanzlerin auch mit
mit erdogan und gegebenenfalls putin die
im moment sind die dinge schwer planbar
wie man sich organisiert aber das ist
ein thema im fokus auch besonders der
deutschen außenpolitik
und wir müssen die möglichkeiten finden
auch im sicherheitsrat der vereinten
nationen besitzen ja auch im
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen
beschäftigen uns damit dass die krisen
die wir haben etwa in syrien aber auch
in libyen wir haben gerade in
afghanistan im moment eine entwicklung
das ist dieses abkommen zwischen den
amerikanern und den taliban gegeben hat
und man uns gebeten hat
friedensgespräche zu organisieren
zwischen der afghanischen regierung und
den taliban das kann jetzt nicht alles
liegen bleiben sondern dass daran wird
genauso intensiv gearbeitet wie bisher
aber eben mit anderen mitteln
es finden nicht mehr so viele reise
stadt nicht mehr so viele persönliche
zusammenkünfte aber in einer
digitalisierten welt wie heute kann man
alles über video konferenz oder telefon
schaltkonferenz sind genauso gut das
darf nicht alles liegen bleiben sagt der
bundesaußenminister live bei bild der
jetzt gerade eine gewaltige
rückholaktion gestartet hat für deutsche
urlauber spricht von einer luftbrücke
und er selbst reist nicht mehr das
halten wir fest aus den gesprächen dank
an den bundesaußenminister und zurück zu
gehen